in a world driven by technology and
Innovation there's a secret Force at
work a group of elite programmers who
possess a unique skill set known as the
code Whisperer well in this new video on
Amazon code whispered we'll unravel the
Mysteries behind the Amazon code
Whisperer a revolutionary concept that
has taken the giant tech industry by
stop but before that do subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon
for more such interesting videos and if
you want to learn more about cloud
computing platforms its services and
various other interesting in-depth
Concepts than our Caltech postgraduate
program in cloud computing will be the
right choice for you this postgraduate
program in cloud computing will help you
become an expert in Azure and AWS and
its related Concepts this in-depth
course lets you master key architectural
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a cloud expert it will help
you become an expert in this designing
planning and scaling Cloud
implementations our cloud computing
course helps you master the core skill
set required a design and deploy
dynamically scalable and reliable
applications on Microsoft Azure and AWS
so do check out the course link
mentioned in the description now let's
get started with the video picture this
a team of Brilliant Minds working
tirelessly to unravel complex scoring
problems and create Crown breaking
Solutions these are the code Whisperers
and their Journey began with a vision to
bridge the gap between developers and
the vast resources of Amazon web
services well it all started with a
realization a profound understanding
that AWS with its extensive range of
services holds immense power to
transform businesses and driven
Innovation however harnessing this power
requires deep expertise and specialized
knowledge that's when Amazon recognized
this Challenge and embarked on a mission
to create a platform that empowers
developers to unlock the troop potential
of AWS and so the Amazon code Whisperer
was born the code Whisperer is not just
a title it represents a unique training
program designed to equip developers
with this skill and knowledge to harness
the full capabilities of Amazon web
services through a series of immersive
workshops Hands-On exercises and
real-world stimulations the code
Whisperers are trained in the art of
optimizing scaling and securing AWS
applications but what sets the code
Whisperers program apart is its emphasis
on collaboration and Community code
Whispers form a tight-knit network
sharing their insights techniques and
best practices with one another as a
code Whisperer you gain access to
exclusive forums webinars and events
where you can learn from the industry's
finest minds and stay up to date with
the latest trends in technology the true
power of the code Whisperer lies in the
ability to solve complex problems
swiftly and efficiently armed with their
Newfound knowledge they are able to
optimize performance reduce scores and
deliver scalable Solutions in recorded
time in fact businesses across the globe
have witnessed the transformative impact
of code Whisperers startups have scaled
their operations Enterprises have
streamlined their workflows and
organizations of all sizes have
experienced unparalleled efficiency and
cost saving so are you ready to become a
part of this Elite group of developers
well you can unlock your potential
embark on a journey of innovation growth
and success with the Amazon code whisper
program well to give you more
perspective over cloud computing
platforms and its Concepts and how our
course can help you Ace them here's a
success story of one of our Learners who
accelerated their career with the help
of our course
and I am currently living in Nigeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
live I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech Chrome Sample video that with
this course I had the choice to study
while I continue and that is how I got
this new job offer with 60 percent
salary high in Finland I will be leading
the cloud computing unit of my new
haircut we cannot wait to start our new
life in Finland we are all remember the
future belongs to those who can whisper
the language of code well this was all
about Amazon code Whisperer if you like
this video then please do give it a
thumbs up and share it with your friends
also if you have any questions then
please feel free to ask away in the
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible thank you and
keep coding staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here